cuz we're gonna be
[Applause]
this was last Monday morning in her life
I like her hustle 541 in the morning in
the airport
she is grinding let's go red sweater
[Music]
sweater just got done with the pitch but
well it was exciting rank and great BAM
we'll see what happens in our sports
early days we should me and AJ are think
about the same things lines be so much
early vaynermedia same thing and you
know what that means the outcomes gonna
be good game operated game over they
don't know yet but this time we're
documenting it
this time we're documenting it good job
boys really excited going to a to an
airbnb to catch a Jets game and then
heading back to LA
[Music]
right so we've got a lot of [ __ ] for a
short little trip see that was the right
answer right good job AJ I got nothing
and literally happened with nothing a
quick little stopwatch a Jets game just
about to post a new episode of dailyvee
short little one for yesterday short
little one for today weekends are always
gonna be a little tricky depending on
the situation but uh more fun more
insights in my day to day just kind of
different scenes different parts of life
only so much I can show you of like
meeting after meeting after meeting but
Sunday holiday time of all of your
aren't doing some gift shopping spending
time with the fam and join yourselves
living life watching football you know
I'm deeply intensely right now thinking
about vaynermedia 2017 and strategizing
new clients offloading some clients I
think they've got the inner talent
exploding AJ we're in an air B&B I mean
this is this is how it happens when
you're three annexed oh Jesus the Jets
won in overtime against the 49ers I'm
disgusted because I really actually
wanted to lose but it is what it is you
know like the team fought and that's
what they do and the coaching staff and
so kudos that I'm gonna come back now
I'm just getting to the airport long day
vanish sports fly to Atlanta
iDate trip to Atlanta commuted to
Atlanta for a meeting caught the Jets
with my brother and now heading back to
LA land around midnight la time gotta be
up at 6:00 a.m. working out just grind
them grind and while they're sleeping
I'm glad you stopped Batman we have a
great holiday take care I will watch 0
minutes and 0 seconds of this game
because I hate football
[Music]
cool in December I'm just gonna work on
email for the next four hours crying for
next four hours midnight you know how it
is super glamorous being an entrepreneur
super fun and easy just all about the
grind
see in our nation it's midnight la I
woke up at 4:30 a.m. la time so we've
been on a 17 and a half 18 hour grind
flew in for one meeting in Atlanta and
Sue back on a rest day
and a weekend in the holiday weekend in
December because I was having a flight
filming sort of the app so just a
classic example of putting in the work
right
got too many people willing to take to
cross-country flights for one meeting
but Boehner Sports is a young company
and when you have a your first year the
ability to be in the finals of a first
round pick and get a chance inside a
first round pick you do it so they reach
down and so you know Brian Luke I feel
like we need you for this woman so I
made it happen so it's tough it's tiring
but your your actions have to match your
ambition if I'm going to talk [ __ ] about
how well Boehner is gonna do in your
sports then then I need to back it up
with with this kind of gruff nice little
grind so if you don't want to put in the
work
you